how do you think gpt4 and all the
advancements with GPT change the nature
of programming
today's Monday we launched the previous
Tuesday so it's been six days the degree
while the degree to which it has already
changed programming
and what I have observed from how
my friends are creating yeah the tools
that are being built on top of it
um I think this is where we'll see
some of the most impact in the short
term it's amazing what people are doing
it's amazing how
this Tool The Leverage it's giving
people to do their job or their creative
work better and better and better
it's it's super cool
so in the process the iterative process
you could um
ask it to generate a code to do
something
and then
there's something the code it generates
and the something that the code does if
you don't like it you can ask it to
adjust it
it's like it's a it's a weird different
kind of way of debugging I guess for
sure the first versions of these systems
were sort of you know one shot you sort
of you said what you wanted it wrote
some code and that was it now you can
have this back and forth dialogue where
you can say no no I meant this or no no
fix this bug or no no do this and then
of course the next version is the system
can
debug more on its own and kind of try to
like catch mistakes as it's making them
but this idea of dialogue interfaces
and iterating with the computer as a
creative
partner tool
I think that's a really big deal